autre point comment laëtitia s'est elle
mis à dos l'opinion publique alors tous
ces revirements tutsi
quand vous voyez que son père se fâche
dès le début que même mamie rock à
balancer des choses pas très aimable que
le père a dit que c'était une menteuse
et cetera les gens sont troublés et puis
tout ça au fond c'est pénible pour tout
le monde on est tous fans de johnny en
aime johnny est ce qu'on s'est fait
raser ces sites soient récupérables
non oui moi je n'en parce que maintenant
on ne la considère plus comme sincère au
début il y avait des polémiques les gens
prenaient partie pour un camp j'allais
dire un clan mais un camp ou l'autre
mais aujourd'hui moi moi au début je
l'écouté avec attention on a
l'impression que tout ça c'était de la
com dès le début on ne sait plus si
c'était vrai on a l'impression qu'elle
nous manipuler et là on a l'impression
qu'elle se sent libérée de toutes les
contraintes qu'elle redevient peut-être
elle-même et que du coup presque presque
je vais dire est peut-être cruel mais
qu'elle oublie johnny que tout ça c'est
derrière elle et que maintenant il se
fout de tout elle et elle s'en fout de
tout elle se fout de nous aussi
non j'ai donc là on la croit plus
justement moi je trouve qu'au contraire
il ya eu une passade où tout le monde la
détestais que le fait de cette nuit avec
ce mec là moi ça me rend plus humaine
que dire enfin elle est vivante elle se
laisse vivre à quelque chose
et du coup on retrouve peut-être une
femme et moi moi en tout cas ça me la
rend plus sympathique je me dis et je
tombe pas du tout sûr être sur le fait
qu'elle l'ait s'est fié à los angeles je
trouve qu'au contraire elle vit sa vie
de femme malgré tout ce qui se passe
malgré le fait que tout repli l'on soit
concentré contre elle
d'accord la transition la transition du
lundi au mercredi entre la veuve éplorée
et là la femme amoureuse c'est vrai nom
est un bien meilleur sort mais c'est à
dire je pense aussi que les jeunes y
cela ça fait tellement de temps que le
cette histoire elle traîne et qui a duré
ferment de situation d'un moment les
gens ils se lassent et vous vous étiez
le comportement de laëtitia ou par toute
cette affaire autour de zonic qu'est ce
qui vous dérange de plus laetitia au
final on oublie qu'on nomme les artistes
et qu'on le budget parce qu'au final
c'est ça le triste puisque le plus
choquant c'est que quand johnny et elle
était là je pense que c'était plus ou
moins soudé ou en façade était soudée et
que et que la de du coup il arrive
qu'ils en profitent pour régler leurs
comptes
et en plus il règle pas en face à face
c'est via des médias interposés je ne
vois pas de 7 ce douar money qui
existait avant est ce que c'est vrai
cette histoire bernard montiel qu'il ya
quelques années il ya un anniversaire
était organisée à los angeles
oui qui était qui a réuni toute la
famille dont ses lueurs temps et que
johnny aurait dit à ce moment là sylvie
fortin pas que tu viens avec moi chanter
sur scène et qu'à ce moment là et dès ce
moment là laëtitia aurait commencé à
très mal le vivre à côté on n'y était
pas mais c'est vrai qu'il ya eu cette
histoire elle a été effectivement très
répété très connu et effectivement comme
elle avait interdit johnny ni pack 2 de
chanter 100% qu'est le titre de david à
l'idée de le chanter sur scène dès le
départ ça n'allait plus du tout alors
évidemment on organise un anniversaire à
los angeles c'est compliqué quand on
habite à paris d'aller faire un
aller-retour comme ça etc
alors évidemment laëtitia avait dit à ce
moment là tu vois tes enfants ils se
déplacent même pas pour toi
tout ça est douloureux de toute façon
est difficile